el maestro del cine iraní y la directora
más radical de esta edición hicieron su
entrada por la alfombra roja de cannes
[Música]
el iraní asghar farhadi regresó a cannes
por la puerta grande con una película
filmada en su país y en su lengua natal
un héroe es la historia de una redención
imposible la de brahím un hombre que
busca desesperadamente salir de prisión
la suerte parece sonreírle cuando su
novia consigue un bolso lleno de monedas
de oro el botín podría permitirle pagar
su deuda pero bryant opta por devolverlo
su buen corazón choca en toda la
película con la deshonestidad del
sistema
édgar para díaz en un héroe una
radiografía de la sociedad rígida y
corrupta y de las redes sociales el
nuevo e implacable espacio público para
mostrar su intimidad
la directora francesa giuliano presentó
en cannes titán un thriller ultra
violento que sacudió a la crítica y el
público
[Música]
titanes a la vez una película de horror
de sexo fantasía y violencia
la heroína atrás de este largometraje
tiene una placa de titanio en la cabeza
implantada tras un accidente 20 años
después
alexia se convierte en una serie
alquiler tras una fusión con un vehículo
la estrella francesa avanza hablando
interpreta aquí a un padre inconsolable
tras la desaparición de su hijo
titan es el segundo largometraje de
giuliano quien somete al espectador a
una experiencia brutal no apta para
almas sensibles